my husband might we've always lived in a
place that only has one bathroom
and one of the fights that we have over
and over is because he takes 45-minute
mansions see that some of you are also
familiar with this phenomenon I don't
know what you guys do in there you guys
go numb from the waist down you've got
holes completely drying out it's like a
crazy back there Ozark I had never seen
this before really guys so I asked him
early on I was like hey why does it take
you so long to do that and he goes well
my doctor told me that it's bad to push
so I don't push I just sit and I'll let
it fall out what are you occasions for
I'm gonna do just grab on to something
sire Sunday gotta go to Costco I feel
like I'm gonna be giving birth Sunday
and you're just gonna lean over my
shoulder like don't push so much worse
because I have irritable bowel syndrome
which means there's no warning for
anything that's gonna happen to my body
like I'll just be in the produce aisle
of the grocery store than my butt was
like crack it startles me you know so we
were in our apartment a few months ago
and my husband went to the bathroom for
one of his sessions and I knew it was
gonna be a session because I could hear
him lock the door but she only does for
number two I'm not sure why I think he
thinks that you live in a youth hostel
just some like confused weary travelers
it's gonna accidentally borrowed you oh
my god sorry I brought it in there oh
shoot in there like nobody it's just me
and you nope
you don't have to log it either that or
I do think sometimes you guys I have
have like a poof oh you know while
you're like sitting there oh you think
we're going to like busted and jumps on
your lap start tickling you know he
needs about 20 minutes into his usual 45
minutes when I start to feel some
fireworks so at X 2
[Laughter]
like hey I'm about to [ __ ] my pants
siren emoji fire emoji just sending a
little urgency he does not respond I can
hear his phone get my text and then I
hear and just continue to watch Arrested
Development so now I'm faced with the
reality that I do not have access to a
toilet and I've got some demons coming
down the chute I'm an apocalypse
survival mode so now I start frantically
looking around our apartment for a
substitute toilet the first thing I see
is the kitchen sink I know I know right
away I was like too high
a lot of gymnastics I'm not qualified
karate
especially in the clutch like that
that's that's a narrow pass pass next
thing I see is my husband's Boston Red
Sox hat which emotionally felt like the
right choice because I would like to
soft serve him some piping hot justice
we've put me in this predicament and I'm
like you know that's a small surface
area I'm not confident with the aim no
path not finally buzzer beater I see in
the corner of the living room there's an
empty cardboard Amazon box some longer
with a faster delivery than Amazon is
never your prime accounts got nothing
away [ __ ] sweating and crying cats
walked up to me with a look on my face I
had never seen
we're not doing on nurse appreciated and
I had never hadn't been in the situation
before so I was going through a lot of
emotions as it was happening mostly rage
I was pretty pissed at my husband for
forcing me to [ __ ] in a box like an old
homeless man well he had his delicate
flower of an [ __ ] gotta enjoy some
nice princess juice just a nice small
day for him meanwhile I'm wiping with a
song I love Brussels bursting my
eyeballs apart they're so pissed so mad
so after I was done I boxed it back up I
was ready to walk the box outside to the
dumpster and right as I was about to
walk out of it that's what my husband
finally came out of the bathroom and he
just saw me standing there with an
Amazon box he goes oh sweet dude my
playstation controller cut and I was
like yeah I think it did
and his reaction brought me more joy and
every Christmas morning combined because
he was so confused he didn't understand
that it was me why would he think that
his sweet little wife were literally
[ __ ] into my enemies